bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
parler de la fin de la série shielk donc
voilà déjà d'avance vous êtes prévenu je
vais devoir spoil la série si je veux en
parler donc si vous n'avez pas tout vu
allez voir tout ça et puis revenez quand
vous aurez tout bon je vous avoue que la
situation est un peu particulière
d'habitude je ne vous donne jamais trop
mon avis sur une série car peu importe
on s'en fout aussi j'ai bien aimé ou pas
nous sommes là avant tout pour analyser
les nouveautés ainsi qu'expliquer ce que
les nouveaux éléments amènent pour le
futur de l'univers Marvel sauf que là à
force de briser le quatrième mur et
mêler la réalité avec la fiction
notamment avec ce dernier épisode qui a
décuplé ce concept et bien en tant que
viewer spectateur nous sommes beaucoup
plus impliqués que d'habitude et Marvel
directement voulu s'adresser à nous au
détriment bah du show comme on en avait
parlé dans la dernière vidéo dédiée à Ch
mais également celle sur l'équipe des
Thunderbolts la finalité de la série
était forcément l'avènement d'un nouveau
Hulk à cause du s'envoler de Jenifer
intrigue qui bien évidemment rappelle un
peu celle de la série Falcon and winter
soldier qui de son côté traité du sérum
de supersolda et le truc c'est que
d'accord sheil qui est une héroïne qui
brise très souvent le quatrième mur qui
a beaucoup de sarcasmes voire qui troll
tout simplement et tout ça la série est
encore plus le final l'a très bien
retranscrit mais le problème c'est que
cela a vraiment été effectué au
détriment du reste comme si Marvel
studio par le biais de la rencontre
entre Jenifer et Kevin souhaitait
simplement troller les fans et les faire
avoir tort car du coup ok personne ne
s'attendait à ça pour le dernier épisode
mais par conséquent tous les éléments un
temps soit peu importants sont passés à
la trappe nous avons regardé huit
épisodes développant un scénario pour au
final se faire troller sur le neuvième
donc l'intrigue principale a été balayée
le personnage de Kling qui possède sa
propre histoire dans les comics a été
réécrit ici et avec la fin imposée par
Jane ce dernier a été annulé pareil pour
le s'envoler permettant la création d'un
nouveau Hulk c'était pourquoi pas le
moment d'amener le Red Hulk mais je
pense qu'ils ont repoussé c'est intrigue
car l'acteur de Thunderbolt Ross a été
ricast mais du coup bah l'intrigue du
s'envoler a été balayée aussi le groupe
intelligentia a été démantelée avec la
réécriture proposée par Jane le
personnage de Titania a été balayé
complètement alors qu'on nous l'attisait
depuis le premier épisode bref on se
retrouve pour la première fois avec une
série où on ne sait pas où nous nous
dirigeons pour la suite et c'est
pourquoi c'est très dur d'analyser la
série sholk et où nous sommes obligés de
plus faire la critique du show que de
vraiment analyser faire des théories etc
mon point de vue Marvel s'est servi du
fait que shihol qui est un personnage
qui brise très souvent le quatrième mur
pour faire son autocritique par rapport
au contenu ainsi du coup que de pointer
du doigt les fans toujours de plus en
plus en attente de grands enjeux
concernant le futur du MCU je pense
qu'il est important de le rappeler mais
la plateforme Disney plus est encore
jeune et cette nouvelle manière de
consommer le MCU par le biais de série
de 6 à 9 épisodes et bien c'est quelque
chose de nouveau et très frais et Marvel
ne s'était encore jamais donné
l'occasion de faire son autocritique par
rapport à ce type de contenu et les
retours des fans personnellement je ne
vous en ai jamais parlé mais je ne suis
vraiment pas fan du concept de mini
série pour introduire des nouveaux
personnages pour moi le problème avec ce
concept c'est que l'on se retrouve avec
du contenu dont 80% et complètement
oubliable en fait en général dans chaque
série le premier épisode est intéressant
car qui permet de poser les bases
l'ambiance et l'intrigue mais ce n'est
que vers le milieu ou fin de série que
cela redevient intense ou un peu
intrigant et à terme au final nous
attendons simplement le final pour voir
ce que nous prévoit l'avenir du MCU mais
c'est quelque chose de piégeux car en
plus on le remarque à chaque fin de
série mais les grands enjeux introduits
sont plutôt réservés pour les futurs
films et en plus de cela quand une série
est dédiée à un personnage qui fait ses
premiers pas dans l'univers
cinématographique de Marvel et bien vu
que ce dernier n'a pas encore de vécu et
d'intrigue passée dans l'univers souvent
nous nous retrouvons avec des épisodes
qui exploitent à donf les origines du
personnage alors que ce n'est pas
spécialement intéressant ce n'est que
mon avis mais je trouve que Marvel
studio devrait beaucoup plus développer
des projets spéciaux un peu comme ils
l'ont fait en gros avec warwolf
c'est-à-dire un programme d'environ 50
minutes une sorte de mini film et je
peux vous assurer que rien qu'avec ça
nous pouvons déjà comprendre solidement
les origines et l'identité des nouveaux
personnages qui apparaîtront dans le
futur de Marvel personnellement je pense
vraiment qu'ils auraient dû faire ça
pour des héros comme moonight Miss
Marvel ou encore sheilk contrairement
aux héros comme Wanda Loki ou encore
Falcon qui bénéficie déjà d'un trig
passé qu'il faut continuer et justifier
pour prévenir le futur de Marvel bref
Marvel studio est en constante évolution
toute façon ils se sont servis de chial
que pour faire leur autocritique et
celle des fans et nous verrons bien dans
quelle direction ils vont se diriger
pour l'avenir malgré ce drôle de final
essayons quand même de voir ce que nous
a apporté la série sheilk et les
potentiel teasing pour les prochaines
productions concernant Jennifer Walters
en elle-même sa crise de colère à cause
d'intelligentia et elkling la poussée à
se faire renvoyer du cabinet d'ollyway
alors vu que Jen a réécrit la fin à sa
sauce il y a des possibilités comme quoi
elle retournerait à son ancien poste
pour continuer à développer la section
de droits super humain néanmoins si ce
n'est pas le cas il est clair que
Jenifer restera quand même une avocate
c'est vraiment un trait de caractère
propre à son personnage et qui va lui
servir énormément à se développer dans
l'univers Marvel typiquement je vous en
avais déjà parlé mais je garde cette
idée en tête il se pourrait qu'elle
avenir sheilk devienne l'avocate des
Quatre Fantastiques et même pourquoi pas
d'autres héros dans les comics sheilk
est très lié à ce fameux groupe
légendaire et nous le savons les Quatre
Fantastiques auront une importance
capitale pour l'avenir du MCU donc pour
moi les personnages se rejoindront
forcément au bout d'un moment de par sa
relation intime avec Matt Murdoch alias
Daredevil il y a également de grandes
chances de revoir sheil que dans les
productions liées à ce héros nous savons
par exemple que Matt réapparaîtra dans
la série echo et puis tout simplement il
y aura la série Daredevil borne again
donc voilà mais dans tous les cas la
condition d'avocats de Jane et sa
spécialité dans le droit des
super-humains et quelque chose qui la
relie facilement à l'entièreté du
casting donc nous pourrions revoir
sheolk très rapidement néanmoins pour
moi l'élément le plus intrigant qui
annonce clairement le retour de Jane
dans le futur c'est l'arrivée de Scar
nous en avions déjà parlé et c'était
l'intrigue obligatoire pour l'avenir de
Bruce Banner mais Hulk lors de son
périple sur sa car à bel et bien
engendré la naissance d'un fils qui a
grandi tout seul sur cette planète où le
temps passe bien plus rapidement que sur
Terre ce qui explique du coup sa taille
adulte mais du coup pourquoi est-ce que
l'arrivée de Scar serait lié au retour
de Jane et bien comme vous en avez été
témoin dans l'épisode final un film Hulk
a été officialisé et ce film devrait
traiter de la raison de la naissance de
Scar et de sa relation avec son père le
truc c'est que la plupart des fans
pensent que ce film serait une
adaptation de l'événement World War Hulk
un événement très connu des comics mais
bon pour être très transparent avec vous
je n'y crois pas du tout pourquoi cela
et bien tout simplement car pour moi
c'est déjà trop tard pour adapter cet
événement pour celles et ceux qui ne le
connaîtraient pas en gros à cause des
crises de colère duques beaucoup de
villes ont été saccagées et énormément
de civils ont été massacrés et pour
résoudre ce problème les Illuminati le
groupe secret réunissant les héros les
plus influents et les plus puissants de
la terre ont pris la décision de bannir
Hulk dans l'espace sans son consentement
et du coup c'est à ce moment où il
atterrira sur sa car et donnera
naissance sans le savoir à ce car et
c'est là où l'événement World War Hulk
intervient car bien évidemment Hulk
réussira à revenir sur terre et plus en
colère que jamais il va souhaiter se
venger des illuminatis qu'il la banni
dans l'espace et va donc partir à la
chasse pour les affronter un par un sauf
que dans le MCU cet événement est pour
moi impossible à mettre en place Hulk
c'est
Otto banni après les événements
d'Avengers l'ère d'ultron il n'en
voulait à personne il a simplement pris
conscience qu'il n'était pas adapté à la
vie sur Terre au final Hulk et Banner
auront énormément évolué au point même
de trouver la sérénité et devenir le
Smart Hulk donc je ne vois pas du tout
comment Marvel studio pourraient
instaurer ce climat de vengeance même
Scar ne semble pas du tout menaçant dans
shield car à la limite ils auraient pu
adapter le World War Hulk par le biais
de Scar qui dans les comics a affronter
et renier son père dû à son abandon sur
sa car mais cela ne semble pas du tout
être le cas actuellement du coup moi je
verrai plutôt un film qui traiterait de
la family Hulk c'est-à-dire l'avènement
d'une équipe composée à 100% de Hulk
nous y retrouverions alors Bruce Banner
Scar son fils ainsi que Jennifer Walters
et puis on n'oublie pas qu'Emile
blancski est toujours de la partie
l'abomination peut faire son retour et
rejoindre pourquoi pas cette team de par
la liaison qu'il a avec she Hulk et vu
que le leader est censé faire son grand
retour et qu'en plus leur red Hulk
devrait également voir le jour dans une
future production cela pourrait donner
quelque chose de vraiment intéressant
donc voilà
écoutez je pense que nous allons nous
arrêter là je n'ai pas grand chose à
dire de plus sur la série je sais
qu'elle divise vraiment beaucoup libre à
vous de l'avoir aimé ou non nous sommes
là avant tout pour essayer d'expliquer
et d'analyser comme toujours j'espère en
tout cas que la vidéo vous aura plu je
me suis un petit peu plus ouvert dans ma
vision concernant Marvel etc n'hésitez
pas à me faire du coup vos retours en
commentaire il y a clairement matière à
débat et je pense que ça peut être très
intéressant de lire vos avis je reste
très curieux de vous lire sur ce
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleu et
surtout à vous abonner à la chaîne car
tout simplement il va être temps
désormais de parler de gros sujets que
le Lionel soit avec vous c'était Argo
rock allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]